indianer da hat man das noch sagen ja
sagen sie das zdf das sagt nein
rassismus ja das zdf geht sogar noch
einen schritt weiter und kreiert neben
dem bereits bekannten n-wort jetzt auch
das wort und bloß nicht mehr das wort in
den mund zu nehmen er schauen sich
diesen beitrag machen hier das kostet
die zdf heute sendung unter einer
facebook diskussion zum beitrag über das
vom markt genommene winnetou buch da
steht also bitte achten sie darauf dass
sie wort in der kommunikation zu
vermeiden da wir rassistisch geprägten
begriffen keine zusätzliche plattform
geben möchte also nicht mal wenn sie dem
zdf schreiben und das wird für
öffentlich dann dürfen sie auch nicht
mehr indianer schreiben sonst wird das
einfach gelöscht beim zdf heute dann
wird der ganze beitrag heraus gelöscht
die winnetou affäre die hat längst ganz
deutschland erfasste diskussion über
völlig übertriebene politische
korrektheit
unser kindheitsidol der apachenhäuptling
winnetou erdacht von karl may
noch heute begeistern uns die filme die
bücher und die festspiele in bad
segeberg und an weiteren orten seit
einiger zeit prangert aber die rockszene
die szene der politisch stets korrekten
eben diese geschichten an der vorwurf
winnetou bedienen klischees weiße nicht
indianer würden sich die kultur der
amerikanischen ureinwohner aneignen und
so weiter und so fort
doch wie stehen die betroffenen selbst
die ureinwohner amerikas zu diesem thema
bild ist im el dorado es dann themenpark
in templin und fragt auch dort nach wie
sehen es die darsteller die ebenfalls
indianischer abstammung sind ich glaube
das ist eine ganz schöne überreaktion
dass der verlag die bücher vom markt
genommen hat warum das ist ein bisschen
zu viel des guten finde ich das ist ja
fast schon publicity
robert packard vom stamme der sioux hat
eine ganz klar
[Musik]
ich bin auf winnetous seite und ich
unterstütze seine geschichten komplett
und bin ziemlich verärgert dass man
versucht ihn quasi auszuradieren ich
fühle mich überhaupt nicht diskriminiert
ich sehe auch überhaupt nichts
diskriminierendes oder gar rassistisches
bei winnetou ganz ehrlich ich habe noch
nie einen indianer in amerika getroffen
der deutsch spricht die alle haben nicht
mal was von winnetou oder kall mei
gehört
nochmal es geht unter anderem darum dass
die geschichten karl mays ein verklärtes
bild der kultur der ureinwohner zeichnen
und diese dadurch diskriminieren
warum müssen wir alles jede person mit
einem etikett versehen
amerikanische ureinwohner deutsche oder
alle diese geschlechtsspezifischen
etiketten das braucht man doch gar nicht
wir sind doch alles menschenleben alle
auf derselben erde es gibt keinen grund
für diese ein teil
[Musik]
fragt man also die menschen die es
wirklich betrifft scheint die diskussion
hinfällig
vielleicht ist ja viel diskriminierender
wenn alle über etwas diskutieren und
streiten ohne die meinung der wirklich
betroffenen einzuholen
[Musik]